kevin is with us in Charlotte North
Carolina hi Kevin how are you hi mr.
Andrew how you doin sir
better than I deserve what's up I am my
wife and I are on baby step two and kind
of wondering if I should show on my
truck yeah help
yeah that's a push okay two guidelines I
use on that one is you should not own
things with wheels and motors totaled up
that equal more than half your annual
income and two can you be debt-free not
counting your house inside of two years
so if you don't sell the truck or you do
sell the truck what's the how much do
you owe on the truck 14,000 just under
14,000 gotcha what's it worth I could
probably get about 24,000 for it okay
and what's her car worth her car is
worth about 20 and we oh just under 20
honest so let's go wash gotcha okay and
so you have forty-four thousand dollars
worth of vehicles right yes sir you have
a boat a motorcycle four-wheeler yes sir
expensive lawnmower
okay what's your household income right
now we're making in between 95 and 100
before overtime yeah when I get much
overtime but okay so let's just say we
say we got $100,000 household income
then using my rule of thumb you don't
want over $50,000 worth of vehicles
right because you have too much invested
in things going down and value at that
point so you're under that you're at 44
you're not under it a lot but you're
hundred how much other debt other than
your home do you have well we just
started your program about a month and a
half two months ago or at ninety
thousand and now we're down to about
eighty three eighty three thousand and
you make a hundred okay can you or will
you do what it takes to be debt-free
making a hundred which is paying off
forty-one thousand dollars a year for
two years that's the plan sir okay you
can do that and you love the truck then
keypad yeah then keep it okay but you're
you know you're basically you could
speak
get up by about six months if you sell
either one of these vehicles okay
that you know that's what we're saying
but that's up to you are you willing to
go through six more months of beans and
rice rice it means no vacations not
seeing this out of a restaurant unless
you're working there and all that kind
of stuff
scorched earth on the lifestyle right
because it's the only way you pull this
off forty-one thousand dollars a year
making a hundred after taxes you're
living on nothing yeah that's that's
tough it's doable I've seen people do it
but dude you're going to the pretty
extreme here okay and that's okay
I think you can make it and if you like
the truck and you're willing to pay that
price to keep it I probably would
because you know otherwise here's what's
gonna happen if you if you sell the
truck you're gonna end up buying another
one a year and a half anyway I'm paying
cash for it yeah
year and a half after you get out of
debt I mean so really there's not a lot
of swing here in what's going on cuz
you'd like this truck and that and
you're in but that's the guideline
overall for the rest of your life paying
cash or not of course paying cash is
what we the only thing we would tell you
to do never have a total of more than
half your annual income tied up in
things that are going down in value
that's what you want to get after there
so good job man